dix sept mille deux cent soixante deux
nouveaux cas de couronnes au virus ont
été enregistrés aujourd'hui la russie
revient aux chiffres du mois de février
dernier les autorités sanitaires
explique la flambée des contaminations
par un mépris total des gestes-barrières
cette évaluation est également partagée
par le kremlin
une des raisons est le bas niveau de
vaccination le mépris total le bas
niveau de vaccination de plus le
caractère sournois de l'infection n'est
pas à négliger
naturellement c'est un sujet qui fait
l'objet d'un suivi permanent par le chef
de l'état il reçoit des rapports
quotidiens à la fois de la part du siège
du gouvernement et des dirigeants
régionaux
il surveille donc la situation de la
manière la plus attentive
c'est la chose la plus importante à
l'heure actuelle quant au changement
dans l'emploi du temps du président il
n'y a pour l'instant aucun changement
le président travaille activement vous
pouvez le constater il ne faut pas
oublier que tous les pays sont
confrontés à une amplitude différentes
de vagues de cette infection
une autre chose est que oui nous sommes
en retard sur le taux de vaccination par
rapport à beaucoup de pays nous sommes
en retard
nous avons peu réussi à cet égard mais
pas parce que quelque chose nous manque
nous avons tout ce dont nous avons
besoin en quantité même plus que
suffisante
tout cela était assurée toute
l'infrastructure a été mis en place
il y a quelques mois moscou épicentre de
l'épidémie en russie a également
enregistré un nouveau record aujourd'hui
plus de 9000 cas en 24 heures
le maire de la capitale sergueï
sobianine a expliqué la hausse des
chiffres des malades par la propagation
du var et en delta ii coronavirus qui
serait plus contagieux et plus dangereux
la ville selon sergueï sobianine
commence à revivre la situation du début
de la pandémie
les dernières données que nous avons
obtenus sont que 89 3 % des malades ont
contracté en coronavirus ayant muté dit
delta qui est un variant
tiens il s'est avéré plus agressif et se
propage plus rapidement et c'est ce qui
est le plus troublant pour le contrer le
statut immunitaire d'une personne ou
comme on dit aujourd'hui le nombre
d'anticorps chez une personne doit être
deux fois plus élevé que pour résister
au virus de gohan en fait nous
commençons à revivre cette histoire mais
avec des conséquences plus graves
c'est pourquoi nous constatons une telle
explosion du taux d'incidence et une
forte augmentation du nombre de cas
d'hospitalisation
c'est vraiment un accroissement énorme
nous mettons un service presque tous les
jours de nouveaux hôpitaux de nouveaux
bâtiments pour lutter contre qu'ovide et
nous arrivons à peine à suivre le rythme
dégager des restaurants exemple du
coronavirus seront offert à mouscou pour
les visites et les gens auront besoin
d'un code qr confirmant leur vaccination
le maire de moscou a ajouté que depuis
le 18 juin la participation spectacle
accueillant du public dans la ville
seraient limitées mille personnes
pourront être présents lors de tels
événements au maximum